hey everyone
welcome pumped for this conversation
about
infinite possibilities and so much more
we have kevin martin joining us on the
show hi kevin
thank you thank you adras it's a
pleasure being here
this is a very critical
topic one that is very deeply resonant
with our true nature
the inexhaustible well of infinite
possibilities is our
true nature
and as
we take on these beautiful sparks of the
infinite
that the possibility space
for us is infinite and to know
that we can pursue
any of these lower trajectories or
our highest excitement towards our north
star towards our calling
and perpetually checking in is that
what's happening right now is that what
i'm pursuing
is that what i'm aligned to it's
critical
yeah and it seems
that the lower
quote-unquote possibilities are one of
exclusion and
the higher possibilities are
possibilities of
inclusion in which uh we experience
more and more of the oneness
of our true nature
so it's really beautiful to realize that
the more we become
undistorted the more
we practice with devotion
the more as a very product of this uh
practice and intention we're gonna
experience
less distortions
in the way which we are choosing
what to experience next
i love that tennis ball
hit you just sent over because
we don't typically think
of these lower possibilities
as excluding oneness
or not resonating as much with the true
nature of reality
one could even see these lower
trajectories as having more of a noisy
mind
and these higher trajectories are more
for those
that know how to quiet the mind
and this can be in a sense abiding more
and more as the i
am and this can be doing that
and aligning yourself with your
transcendent noble aim divine
north star calling and also
communing more and more with what is the
source
of even the i am
yeah so i remember
that uh last time we had a conversation
and what came out from that conversation
is uh
something that i was dealing with
because uh from one side
i've always been very devoted to the
path of self-realization
and the other side i
feel like it's really relevant in this
life to
to achieve and to create manifest the
vision
yes and during the conversation you
pointed to the fact that in the way in
which i was shedding there was an
eagerness
to come out from the stillness in order
to go towards the manifestation
and that eagerness is a way in which
we want to be separated
from that pure awareness in which the
vision in which are the calling is
already included
you don't need really to go toward it
you are pulled
you generate it from
the state of inclusivity in which the
calling the manifestation division
is already here
so would it be fair to say something
then
that as you quiet the mind
the noisy mind more and more and you
remove
the possibility space of trajectories of
the lower ones which also include a lot
of
suffering a lot of anxiety depression
malevolence
you're trying to seek peace and
happiness externally in maya
rather than recognize as you abide more
and more as the i
am you recognize the very nature of
being or awareness is
as has been said for millennia such at
ananda existence consciousness bliss
so you stop extracting peace and
happiness from creation but rather you
recognize your true nature is peace and
happiness so this
trajectory already has a lot less
malevolence and suffering and anxiety
and depression which is fantastic which
is what everybody is seeking everybody
seeking
peace and happiness and love and wisdom
and prosperity unity
alignment and actualization so that's
this next one
we could say that abiding as
the i am automatically
as kevin was saying produces
the highest calling is that what you
were saying
exactly and uh these are also as being
and still is the paradox of my life
because uh yeah they are
it's like okay uh
abiding in stillness but
who's going to go to the grocery store
how do i get the food if i abide in
stillness
[Laughter]
yeah so you basically carry the
stillness
with you to the grocery store
yeah exactly
and it seems that there is this
blueprint
that uh can get activated more and more
can
express itself more and more as we
dissolve more and more
into this i am the blueprint gets
activated
perfect blueprint activation with
dissolving into i am
yeah because the zero point is not
really the end there is a
still a purpose that is still an
exploration
that wants to take place on its own
without the mind trying to control
things
it will happen
so the
eagerness will end up being a
spontaneous
arising from stillness of highest
excitement to go to the grocery store
yes and plus there is also
a higher intelligence there when you
will go to the grocery store
there will be something guiding you
coming through you that is gonna inform
in some other ways the different things
that you will engage with
in the world
yes
so if you go to the grocery store from a
place of
a lack or a need
or a layer of conditioning
you might not be as guided by
the one intelligence you might be more
guided by a layer of conditioning that's
trying to fulfill a distortion
so you might not be subtle enough to
notice when you get pulled to
some high fructose corn syrup in the
grocery store
or you might not be you know subtle
enough to
recognize that when the
soul a meeting of the souls of potential
meeting of the souls is taking place
that you're not
subtle enough to detect that the one
intelligence is trying to guide you
toward that to
be a radiant lucid bliss and peace
for someone else that
is interested in it but doesn't yet know
it in manifested form
and so you're acting as guidance
but if you're not subtle enough you
might not
see that you need to basically be
abiding
in the i am perpetually
and in doing so
you perpetually abide in the stillness
and the emptiness
coming from pure love light rather than
conditioning
and as you do so you begin to also see
the oneness
omnipresent as the background
undercurrent of all that is happening
and surrender to that divine
intelligence unfolding and you're
calling manifesting
from that most purely
yes there is a
a powerful gift
that each one of us is here
to give to the collective
and abiding in the iem
is what allows us to become more and
more aware
aware of the different synchronicities
that will guide us into the direction
of discovering more and more of our
mission
more and more of our coding
as an example uh for you atlas
your calling if i remember right is uh
people
experiencing a truth
i'm sure that the rada there were
different
things that led you here and now
you are showing up daily
and you're keeping this as a your north
star
and there are different uh things
that you're organizing in your life in
order to be in alignment
with this intention
and this is our we are being of service
to the collective and you're sharing
your gift allowing people
to remember more and more of their
calling more and more of their
original essence
yes so if i'm getting this right when we
talk about
coming from source like what we were
playing with when we were talking about
bentino and anurag's mirror talks
episode where they
specifically dove into depth on the
subject
purifying where you're coming from to
make it so that you're coming from
source that is
analogous to us coming from
i am
yeah so that's already a pretty profound
idea is that coming from source is
pretty much the same thing as coming
from god
coming from i am
so the only distortions
really are the
layers of conditioning
of all these lack beliefs and all these
needs to be validated and seen
yeah so
and uh there are so many
distorted paths that we could take in
this moment
how beautiful it is that in this moment
we have the free will
to take a distorted path
how beautiful it is that you have the
freedom
to explore infinite
degrees of distortions
geez
[Laughter]
and learn from this
yeah and that's that's typically what
happens when you get one of those little
thought clouds that arises in the mind
and if you're not really sensitive and
trained
you don't see it as something that
arises and passes
so that's basically a trajectory
possibility that's showing up
saying hey what about this
in the potential of infinite
possibilities
and the more sensitive you become
the more you recognize that that
trajectory that just arose as a thought
cloud in the mind is not in the i
am it's not in the highest excitement
and so
that's a trajectory that arose in past
and that
is one of those infinite
trajectories of distortions that
kevin was just mentioning
because i'm thinking about so many
like even right now like
either one of us could just step away
from the zoom call and like go walk over
to go on a walk or something you know
but since we know the other person as
the i am
then why would we do that to ourselves
i could take this camera right now and i
could
start beating it with a hammer
all right like
there's so many of these trajectories
yeah yeah there is so much freedom in
that
and the knowing that actually it doesn't
is not relevant maybe for you to explore
a certain possibility
but it's much more relevant to explore
other possibilities and the only reason
why you are here
in this density
i don't want to get so much into that
but especially if you are
a wanderer you decided to come here
to explore this possibility of being a
human
of feeling uh dense emotions
of getting into conflicts of
having experience with certain
relationships certain hardships
yeah that's a really important point
for people to remember is that you came
here
you made a choice to come here you came
here as
part of the exploration of the
inexhaustible creativity of source
and for you to know that you've
taken on a divine
transcendent calling of
unlocking the frozen free will of the
third density of the collective
and unleashing that towards the more
vapor-like love-light leela that is
actually happening
is much more exciting
than becoming a slave to the carrots of
maya
and uh what it seems is that uh these
are higher trajectories
these higher possibilities
they have they are more dense with love
light
because each one of these possibilities
is you exactly
and in the less distorted possibility
we are simply aligning ourselves so that
now we have an experience that is less
distorted
that is more much more as it is
and as you have experience of these as
it is
there is a a unique reflection
that you're going to experience you're
going to live
from and as you're calling
yep i really adore your focus on the
infinite possibilities i think you do a
really good job at honing in on that and
we've only started the episode on it
it's really good it's really important
you from the very
point if you go back like a tunnel
in your own perception
and you go back like a tunnel and you
become aware of awareness
and then you keep going back to even the
very
source of awareness itself so you see
the source of awareness
and the source of realities and so
if you become really aware of the fact
that when you go
all the way back to nothingness that
what manifests is inexhaustible
creativity
and that the nature of that is infinite
possibility
like kevin and i are discussing first
and then
from there recognize that
you've decided to come here for this
exploration
and that now your nature here as this
mind body spirit complex is to again
recognize that your nature is infinite
possibility
and from here now see the trajectory
space
just like as above with source
inexhaustible creativity so below
with your life inexhaustible creativity
so recognize that you have an
infinite amount of trajectories with
your mind body spirit complex right now
but what did you come here for
did you come here for a rolex
did you come here to for one night
stands on tinder
did you come here to
shepherd or steward the planetary
awakening
and decipher that for yourself
as soon as possible it's already
naturally unfolding
but reflect on it
so i've been really appreciating how
you focused your you are on this and how
good of a communicator you are about
this
kevin it's only the beginning of the
podcast convo and i'm so
jacked for the rest of it
it is great to be here
how did that as a buff so below resonate
with you
the as above with sources infinite
inexhaustible
creative possibilities as well as the so
below
with the mind body spirit complexes
infinite possibilities yeah so this is
interesting because uh it's something
that i was exploring
the last day in my ex in my exploration
of the world actually and just uh
looking at these uh
body minds looking at what we created
right now and uh prior to this
realization
i was saying that uh for me
synchronicities
where uh when something would happen in
your reality like
it was really precise and you attracted
that experience
or that 111 as a timing on your phone
but uh what i'm realizing and what
you can realize is right now just by
looking at everything that we're
creating
is that everything is synchronized with
source
all aspects of the simulation are
synchronized
with source yes
even the creation that we are creating
right now
as an example uh the internet
through the internet we cannot be
connected
we can download files from the cloud
and you as a channel for source you a
source
you can channel all the elements of your
coding
in the body-mind speed complex
so everything is synchronized and my
guess
is that the more the densities
of the planet will increase
the more certain people will become
channels to
for new creations
that will allow us to experience more
of these uh infinite possibilities
yeah here's another way to synchronize
our last two points
that the nature of the
inexhaustible creativity of source
is greater
than the nature of the infinite
possibilities
of our mind body spirit complex here
now because the mind body sphere complex
here right now
is stuck in a specific civilization
with a specific plane and orbiting a
star with a split with a specific
history in a specific future trajectory
landscape
and with you are
trapped to your neurobiology right now
the specific
design of a cell and the specific way
that it functions
so
because when you really jump to the
inexhaustible creativity of source
you'll recognize that there's an
endless possibility of mind body spirit
complexes
vehicles neurobiology to design
planets stars civilizations it's endless
and so right now you're in
one of those your nature
is the source of infinite possibility so
the more you identify as that
the better so you have to negate and go
all the way back
to that first for you to know yourself
truly
and then you can include awareness and
then you can include
your unique spark of the infinite your
costume
but if you only identify as your spark
of the infinite as your costume and you
don't know you're actually the source of
infinite possibilities
then you'll accidentally create
suffering and malevolence because you
won't know your true nature
so okay so after you've done this
process of negation followed by
inclusion after you've done that process
then you recognize that one of the main
things that
we'll be focusing on is the infinite
possibilities that
are present here for the civilization
for each mind body spirit complex
must be maximized
in terms of will choice self-awareness
sovereignty and callings
and so that's the coolest thing that you
can do
yeah so one of the concepts that i
really like from
the little one is uh the accumulation of
spiritual mass exactly
and we could even say
that the infinite possibilities
are all part of the spiritual mass
so in what a work of self-realization is
that you're bringing
all of these possibilities and you're
collapsing them
more and more and more and more and more
and more and more and more and all of
this time space
time space love light love light love
it's coming all in one
one one one one one one
one one aware of itself
and from here you don't even care
but there will be a uniqueness that will
be projecting
to the world and seems
that by abiding in this you won't really
care
[Laughter]
it seems so because you'll be
all of it and none of it yeah
i liked what you said about because
what can happen is that then we find our
purpose in this life
we find our vision we find our calling
but then what happened is that
there is still the human
attached to it
and that's actually the distortion
because it's the human
with the vision which uh is what will
actually be projected
all the time in this simulation but the
question is
do you want to be identified with it
yeah do you want to be the hero or do
you want to be nobody
yeah such a good way to put it the
vision being attached to the human
rather than the vision being from the
source
of inexhaustible possibility
so as you
create spiritual mass for yourself by
unfreezing
your will and choice and
becoming more focused on purely
serving others as a steward shepherd for
the planetary enlightenment
you'll notice that the coolest thing
that you can do is
unfreeze the will and choice
for those that are still
in the third density matrix
and as you do that you'll have the
choice
is it going to be the i am the
lightbringer atlas
that is bringing the vision forward
or is it going to be i am
source i am nobody
this is hollow bamboo
and so one of them is going to get
inextricably attached to the carrots of
maya
and the other one has no chance of
getting attached to the carrots of maya
yeah and
that i really think that
it will uh inevitably happen
because uh what's coming to mind is that
uh
if we are here in the first place
exploring the third density
is because we are attached to something
to begin with
otherwise we will not be in this
simulation
we are all kids here
[Laughter]
that's why we are here
the martial arts belts
why would you be here if you hadn't
learned
if you had already learned how to
master the martial arts belts moving
between
these densities you wouldn't be here
you're here because you're in school
yeah even
if you identify yourself
as a wanderer as a soul that is here to
be of service to humanity
the only reason why you still want uh to
be
of service to humanity in these active
ways is because uh
there is a part of you that seems that
is
resonating with their calling
of suffering and the only reason why you
can eat it
is because you're not fully in the
source so you're still attached to
something
that's why we're here we are in the
bubble
[Music]
um
so
because the soul has yet to
fully unite
with source it
is attached to the narrative of planet
earth's
suffering and incarnation
for school to affiliate itself more with
source and less with
attachment to planets suffering
yeah because if we then see the old
cosmology and we see
what happens to the is sulfur that is uh
in the later six density it starts to
get
pulled into the gateway timeless gateway
to
source that is uh if i'm not wrong the
seven density and here you don't really
have a choice you don't have free wheel
anymore to go back
your free wheel has been disturbed
completely
that uh distortion of free will
that is still a distortion because you
still have the power
to choose distortions the power to
choose distortion the free will
is a distortion
the being of seven density is not even a
being anymore
he has he she has no source he has no
will to be of service
to a simulation like this
and if you really are here to be of
service
to humanity and bringing uh
these codes these vibrations
from your native density at the same
time here
with all of us you have the possibility
to refine
your own distortions because uh er
is like being inside of the water here
everything is dense
so you're gonna feel the things so if
you can feel the things
it's more easy to work on them
and more feeling equals
more easy lessons
learned when you feel less
when it hits you less it's not as great
of a catalyst so the very fact that we
can
feel makes it easier for the lesson
to happen so we're in the most dense
one of the most dense feeling
places here yeah
we're in one of the most dense
simulations
out there
from what i can tell so far you're one
of the most
aware and awake to
the law of one not only in the no limit
society but just in general that i've
met
which is awesome
i you know the first time that the law
one was
was introduced to me
i didn't want to read it
because a photo that all channeling
materials
were to be avoided that's what one of my
previous teachers said
he's a public teacher so maybe i can
share it
david hawkins that created the scale of
consciousness
i had no idea that david hawkins
said don't trust channeled material
i had no idea he's very profoundly
influential so the fact that he would
say that would be so weird
yeah because uh and that's interesting
also right it's really fascinating to
see the factor that you can still have a
high level of realization
but still you're here still you have to
learn so
this is what david walken is saying in
his teachings in his books
to avoid the astral realm and to avoid
the
channeling materials but and i agree
with it
i agree with it because the law one
it's unique it's a
a real clear
transmission so we could say that it's
even right to say that
because the law one
from what i experienced we can say
maybe i didn't explore all of them but
we can say
that is one of the least distorted
maybe channeling materials out there i
don't know all of them but
i know that a lot of people that i
really resonate with
they share the same view yeah likewise
yeah because there is a there has been a
real
accurate preparation for this
transmission to take place
and when you go to leader you can really
feel
that ra is she is coming from source
yes
that's probably why there's such a
strong
gravitation towards
the lava1 material by continuo
team u
the me
because of that because it feels
quite
selflessly purely brought forth
yeah and to say the truth now i
i it's safe to assume that actually
i learned i became aware of the low one
eighty percent true bentino twenty
percent through the material
because bentino actually point is
pointing us
into learning the law one from the
essence
yes because uh he often say
says that this book is not about the
tarot cards
it's not about the ufo yeah all of these
things are cool but
look at what lies pointing to yeah
yeah he's pointing to the direct path
he she's pointing to the direct path
and it's and not only the direct path
for the individuated mind body spirit
complex to
know to know their infinite possibility
space and to see everything as catalysts
to remove distortions towards lovelight
leela
but it's also a metaphysical map
in terms of the true nature of a
seven density ascent with a cyclic
cosmological creation
yeah because
what is said in the law one
either that this density
it's often said it's often repeated that
this density
is not the density of understanding
okay so as the third density
body mind speed complexities we actually
don't have the ability
to perceive the entire cosmology
of the creation of the one that we are
even if if any fuel
as a mind body speed complex
within a lot of attention
on awareness itself even if you're able
to go beyond
and transcend completely reveal
the veil you still won't be able
to understand alone the entirety of
creation
because in this third density that
signal
doesn't come true that's why
it's such a blessing to all
human beings of this simulation
to ever a precise material
as the low one that can point us
to that which we cannot understand
it really resonates with me that similar
to
bentino
and yourself with the law of one
and with bentino with i'm not sure how
familiar
you are with this argothe maharaja and
sadhara mishwar maharaj
yeah a little bit yeah some quotes here
and there yeah
yeah yeah i would say that
[Music]
there's a great similarity
in that regard with the direct path
pointings
with what they've been able to
directly point
and ramana maharshi
has also done a really good job
yeah so in a sense channeled material is
great
on the metaphysical roadmap
and sort of the the direct experience
of entheogens
or the mystic traditions
or aphorisms
are also really good pointings
and to
leverage those in the hollowing
cleaning out the pipes
to be a pure channel for
the one infinite creator yeah
yeah so yeah amazing
and uh adding and sharing more regarding
what you said right now
in order to balance the view that they
kind of gave to david tokens
one of the quotes that is still on my
art
of david dawkins is a straight and
narrow
is the puffer waste no time yeah
exactly and i love it and why he says
that
because you actually are here
to realize the ultimate
you are here to realize the one you are
here
realize source the path to it
is straight so that wastes no time
[Laughter]
dedicate your life to it it doesn't have
to look like anything
it's about your intention
i'd like to bring us
back to what we were saying at the
beginning and weave us up there
where
coming from the i am is coming from
the seventh density it's coming from
god so it's coming from
where there's no free will anymore
your infinite possibilities collapse to
only the highest
it is liberating to be free from
even your calling being free from your
vision
also having no playground
anymore
so
yeah that seven density
seems to be really correlated with
uh your clown chakra your
seventh chakra that is actually the
gateway back to source
the very stillness itself
will guide most
harmonically
in the creationary ascent of the
simulation
you said that it will guide in the
center didn't get the word
guide most harmonically
in the unfolding of the creationary
simulated ascent
so get out of your own way um
yeah but nobody wants to die before they
die
yeah that's always the big joke
so that you have to die before you die
yeah
one question that is coming up is
what is that i can't give up right now
what uh strategy can i give up right now
what thought forms
can i give up right now
can i even give up the objection to give
up things
what is the answer to your own question
there is a now kind of uh
momentum that has been accumulated
through time
so i'm gravitating more and more
into yes i can
i'm ready i can do this right now
and then of course
there is uh there are distortions
that are not allowing the complete
dissolution of all the simulation that
i'm creating for myself
and i think there is a beauty
in accepting at the same time
the factor that you probably
need to accept the lesson that you're
creating for yourself
the struggles exactly
you are here to learn from all of this i
like
the old
word that you can discover by going
into the low or one point info
and typing the word catalyst
yeah such a good one how many things
you're gonna learn
there about the nature
of catalyst that's right it's a very
important word in science as well
biology chemistry
[Music]
so physics cosmic
you set up your own school
yeah yeah so accept yourself
which is the second know yourself accept
yourself become the creator
the second is accept yourself so accept
your school
and i would say know yourself
is my answer to your question which is
what can you give up
well when you know yourself at the most
intimate deep level you become the most
subtle monitor of yourself
and when you become the most subtle
monitor of yourself
then you can give up all of the lower
trajectories because you will actually
see those algorithms arise
and you'll tell them
i see you now for what you are
yeah you have no power over me yeah like
the mantra
i love you i'm sorry please forgive me
thank you i used that for a little bit
then i realized that uh there was still
the ego the persona
resting the mantra so i had to let go of
that even
but it's great if you feel like it's
relevant for you to say the four words
or even true i love you thank you to
each catalyst to which experience to
each emotion
i love thank you and transmuting that
energy
into more of that which you truly are
i would say that that's probably the
most
important
school lesson class
part of the pedagogy
is when you come
and incarnate
that you want to get really good
as soon as possible at
deciphering
between when you're coming from
distortions versus when you're coming
from
source i am
yeah that one thing will change uh
yeah a lot in our experience it's
probably the most what is more than that
namely one thing name one thing that's
more than the deciphering
between source i am versus distortions
yeah it's all there is right yeah
and we will stop needing the different
uh
catalyst to remind ourselves of doing
that
exactly yeah stop needing catalyst
yeah that's great
yeah so
perfect there are distorted
possibilities
where a lot of catalysts
are gonna be there
and other and something that i really
like love
about this opponent again there is the
concept of
taking a 100 responsibility
yeah so if something happened
instead of blaming and projecting
what uh they're suggesting is
to ask the question what that is in me
that is creating this experience exactly
why
am i creating this experience for myself
yeah
what do i have to learn
that's the shift from
again as we talk about source i am
versus distortions
and i like this visualization it's
really simple
it's like the onion layer is the
distortion
then the source i am is the radical
alignment
it's that
the onion layer that's the distortion
is victim consciousness
when the mind body spirit complex takes
no responsibility
and then the the source i am alignment
is the full 100 responsibility
perpetual it's the creator consciousness
this is victim consciousness this is
creator consciousness
yeah man i was a [ __ ] victim for the
longest [ __ ] time bro
so long so wrong and
i'm sure you were too yeah
yeah yeah yeah
the symbols of life
still different areas in life in which
we still feel
like victims maybe
and uh right now there is a
right now there is a collective catalyst
that we are all experiencing
the collective catalyst that we are all
experiencing
is in the form of this word that i don't
know if i can say it in the channel
but we are all limited
in our expression we are in a
lockdown
so what is that we have to learn
collectively in order to
transcend the need of having this
experience
and how easy it is right now
to fall again into the victim and saying
it's all the government's fault
for their fault i didn't do nothing
i was not there in that lab why should i
take responsibility for this
why should you
it depends if you want to see everything
as you or not
really it boils down to that when you
look at
kevin do you see a separate entity
i'm getting to a place where i don't
i just see kevin as my body i see the
whole universe as my body
and so if you once you get to that point
when you look at the planet
you no longer see a
you no longer see the united states
national
propaganda between the polarized
left and right as
something to victimize yourself to but
you recognize that you
are literally the creator of both of
those propaganda arms
as in a sleeping mechanism purposely
purposely use the purposeful creation of
a veil
the one intelligence being able to veil
itself
from itself so that it can go through a
process
of awakening and remembering its true
nature by
piercing out of the labyrinth that it
created for its own endarkenment
[Laughter]
yeah kevin i gotta say bro this has been
one of my favorite
interviews in a while seriously bro it's
been one of my favorite conversations in
a while
you're one of my new best friends in the
no limit society
i'd love it we're gonna do these more
often
you just you know you know and you're
really clear
and you teach me a lot and i love you
and i'm pumped
thank you atlas for uh this space
for us being here sharing learning each
other from each other
at so many levels giving to each other
the space to share and explore
the different possibilities that are
available here
what's coming true right now
is that uh this month i had uh
two really powerful conversations and uh
we are coming to the same point as right
now
and it seems kind of weird it seems kind
of out there
but what we asked ourselves was
and was serious can we take 100
responsibility
to change to harmonize
the planet the world can can we do that
is it possible can i can you
changing the world really um
um
you are the very
entirety of the creation
undergoing the process
of piercing through the veil
of its own creation to learn
how to love itself through all of its
individuated expressions and experiences
and catalysts
and interactions
you are the entirety of it
you are just intoxicated by
the contracted identity of being a
finite
separate person it's all it is
it's one game of identity
it's all it is as i said in the law of
one
there is no lack there is no disharmony
it is all about identity
everything is about identity you're
stuck
identifying yourself as a person
rather than identifying yourself as
one step up is the very i
am the formless being awareness
that is eternal and impersonal that is
god
and one step past that is the very
inexhaustible
source of creativity the very one
infinite creator so you've completely
purposefully brainwashed yourself into
being a person through the intoxicated
delusion of maya
lakshmi with little carrots dangling you
around
and all you gotta do
is expand
yourself to be the entire universe
and then to dissolve yourself to be
the very nothingness of the
inexhaustible source
and in doing so you
recognize your truest nature
which is beyond coming and going
beyond birth and death
beyond the endless infinite creations
and immersing yourself in them
it's cool to recognize your truest
nature as
deep sleep it is cool to know that
but what do you do after knowing that
you bodhisattva the [ __ ] out of the
creation that you're in
you atlas the [ __ ] out of the creation
that you're in
so enjoy being in perpetual service to
others
because that's the name of this game and
realign yourself
like a hyper vigilant analyst of your
every frame of movie
away from your distortions and towards
your source i am-ness
mm-hmm yeah so
i really love your style of pointing
because uh what seems relevant for you
is that
you're creating the space for it by the
way just saying you're creating the
space for it we are all creating this
space
because for you what's relevant
is that people are actually experiencing
the truth
yeah and what is actually the highest
level of truth
yes is it the news
the simulation
this space in which atlas is pointing uh
constantly
with our absolute devotion to the truth
that we all share between allah are
is it the truth a conspiracy theory or
is uh
something that goes beyond all
i would say this would be a good time to
explore something with kevin
so
take on the identity
of getting 100
out of your own way
[Music]
get 100
as what was formerly allen
and what is now atlas
so there's been an upgrade
in identity an upgrade in
union with the nature of reality
get even atlas the one that has united
more
with the nature of reality out of the
way
and make it a hollow bamboo
a clean pipe
and practice speaking
as source as
i am
i am that which is communicating
about my own creation
helping my own creation
recognize what it is doing
it is here to play it is here to explore
it is here to learn about
itself through veiling itself
and piercing through that veil
in an endless amount
of ways to undergo
all different types of catalysts
and experiences and shedding away
distortions
towards uniting with me
perpetually endlessly across all
possible creations
this is one of my most beloved creations
treat this creation like it is your
creation
treat this creation like it is your
beloved creation your beloved playground
your beloved exploration of
your own love light
see through all of the individuated
costumes
as an illusion of separation beautifully
individuated fireworks
yet see beyond that to the one body
that i am
and abide more and more as that to
dissolve your distortions and to
dissolve the suffering
and the malevolence and the anxiety and
the negative emotions
that are trying to guide you away from
your distortions
and back to the source i am-ness
that is all i would say that
that process is the best
process that i've ever learned how to do
and it
has been catalyzed by
v so v i would say
is the most clear
channel of source i am right now
he gets out of the way and just is that
hollow bamboo
clean pipe and i i just
it's just out of taste and out of
resonance that that's how the atlas soul
feels attunement and so he's been a
major catalyst for me there and i would
say that
you do a really good job as well and i'd
be curious
how when you
practice getting out of your way
repeatedly
what would happen
what happens what i do that
how the the process how the process
looks like
yes okay
and if you would even feel comfortable
doing
an exploration of that right now
okay like a guided meditation
yeah basically coming from the hollow
bamboo
of source i am yeah
so we can explore for these
starting uh directly from the end
directly from the gateway to source
which are either
symbolized in the crown chakra
in the seventh chakra
here in the top of your head you don't
want to be focused on the top of your
head
you just want to realize that teaser
is the gateway to source
from here spontaneously
the energy of source flows down
to the third eye
[Music]
here you won't allow any
and all distortions present in this
energy center to be empty
allow any and all distortions
present in the symbol that we call the
third eye
to dissolve more and more into the love
and light
of source
as the third eye become more aware of
itself the energy of source flows down
to the truth tracker
in the 12th chakra what you're realizing
that diesel is the energy center
whether infinite expression
is expressed in every moment
if this infinite expression is not
expressed in this moment
let go of any and all judgments and
simply dissolve
all distortions into the empty space
as the 12th chakra becomes more and more
empty
more can be expressed
as the energy of the crown chakra of the
source flows down
the fourth chakra the heart chakra
becomes aware of itself
here you may be aware of any of those
sensations
and without identifying with any
sensation
you want to dissolve
all blocks to the infinite love that
wants to radiate
from the energy center of your heart
into em into emptiness
as their chakra becomes more and more
empty
more and more love can be expressed
through your unique
body mind speed complex
as more and more distortion get
dissolved into this
pure i am
the energy of source spontaneously flows
down with no
intention it flows down spontaneously
to the third chakra to the third energy
center
yeah you want to dissolve
all identities associated with the human
identity
you want to recognize yourself as that
space of stillness as that
pure awareness free from attributes
you want to realize that uh you're not
the body you're not the mind
you are the space in which all of these
is happening
as a data the energy center becomes more
aware of what either
the energy of source flows down
to the second energy center
here all heavy emotions
fears angriness
can be spontaneously dissolved
into the love and light of the one
infinite
as a more space is uh
revealed the energy of source
can flows down to the root chakra
the energy of source here has completed
its own journey of exploration
here you are a wall all seven chakras
into one
into the source that you are
yeah because your calling is people
experiencing truth so
you have to reach them right we have to
reach people
through the symbols yes of the
simulation
exactly that's how we learn too
through the symbols of the simulation
exactly
and the symbols of the simulation follow
a power law where there's
only a very select few tail end symbols
that have the greatest attractor
capacity for catalyzing the most
awakening
and so an adepts responsibility is to
parse through the civilizational catalog
of symbols
for those that awaken fastest
yeah and these uh i think that can bring
us to a really interesting point
as an example from what i can remember
there has always been this desire to
find that one thing
it's something that i shared with you
the last time
and this desire to find this one thing
is what attracts you basically
to these uh refined teachings that
you're sharing right now that you're
sharing right now
because otherwise there are so many
quote-unquote distractions
in the spiritual world in the spiritual
market
but why are you here listening about the
direct path
isn't it boring there is no magic here
there is nothing
fancy it's just atlas pointing you back
to the truth
kevin yeah and all our guests that are
high level too
that's why that's why we got attracted
to
the symbols that were most directly
pointing and that's why we
now take what we've synthesized and
distilled
and are working on simplifying it to
even explain latin five
and delivering that to those that are
seeking
yeah move yourself away from the bag of
mixed frequencies
i feel like we had so many profound
bits
so many good ones
coming from source is coming from i am
the blueprint activation that comes with
stillness
all of the cool stuff we talked about
with the law of one we'll put the link
in the bio below
lav1.info we'll put that below for you
guys
abiding as the source iem versus the
distortions
and stop needing catalysts what are the
top
symbols to rocket you to source i am
fastest
there was a lot of other really good
points those were just some from the
notes
and we'll do another pow wow soon
and there's so much to still talk about
with infinite possibilities people
manifesting their visions
self-realization continued explorations
of the law of one
so good
do you feel satisfied to rap totally
totally
perfect thank you kevin thanks for
coming on the program
i cannot say how much i'm grateful for
this really
indescribable gratitude on my end as
well yeah
yeah this is the start of a beautiful
soul attunement pumped
pumped um
thank you thank you yeah thanks everyone
for tuning in also
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below on the episode
let us know what you're thinking if the
video brought you value give it a like
helps algorithm
subscribe if you haven't to the channel
already and share the video with people
that you feel like this would resonate
with
and do check out the law of one the
links in the bio below
if that is calling get out of your own
way
get your conditioning out of the way
abide as the source i
am-ness and maximize our potential here
in this creation
infinite adoration thank you
bye everyone
huh